So yes, in my code, I switch between styles. I let the circumstances decide which is worthwhile. The code is more what you call guidelines than actual rules. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 12, recorded on January 27th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we talk about parentheses, formatting, and so much more. How do you feel about redundant parentheses? Oh, redundant parentheses? I'm a very big fan of redundant parentheses oh redundant parentheses i'm a very big fan of redundant parentheses um like if if i think there's any chance that the that the code can be read misread without the redundant parentheses i'll add them like let me put it to you this way if i have to ask myself
所以是的，在我的代码中，我会在不同的风格之间切换。我让具体情况来决定哪种风格更有价值。代码与其说是实际的规则，不如说是你所谓的指导方针。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 12 期，录制于 2021 年 1 月 27 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯将探讨括号、格式化以及更多内容。你对冗余括号有什么看法？哦，冗余括号？我是冗余括号的超级粉丝，哦，冗余括号，我是冗余括号的超级粉丝，嗯，如果——如果我认为代码在没有冗余括号的情况下有任何可能被误读的风险，我就会把它们加上。让我这样对你说，如果我必须问自己
hmm how does uh order of operations? That means that I'm going to add redundant parentheses. So if it's something where the order of operations is not immediately, I'm 100% certain of what it is, I'll add parentheses. Like for example, if I'm doing something like A less than B and B less than C, I'll probably put the A less than B and the B less than C in parentheses, even though I don't need them, just for clarity. In general, I'm a fan of verbosity. I don't like short identifier names when you can make them longer and clearer um i although the one place where i'm not a fan of verbosity is um i omit the braces for an if statement or a for statement um if i don't need them uh and apparently i'm like the only person in my team at work that does this.
嗯，运算顺序是什么？这意味着我要加上冗余括号。所以如果遇到运算顺序不是一眼就能看出来、我百分之百确定的情况，我就会加上括号。比如，如果我在写类似 A 小于 B 且 B 小于 C 这样的代码，我可能会把 A 小于 B 和 B 小于 C 用括号括起来，尽管我并不需要它们，但为了清晰起见还是会加。总的来说，我是冗长的支持者。当你可以把标识符名字取得更长、更清晰时，我不喜欢简短的名字。嗯，不过我唯一不赞成冗长的地方在于，嗯，我省略了 if 语句或 for 语句的大括号——如果我不需要它们的话。而且显然我是公司团队里唯一这么做的人。
No, I do the same thing. And then people get really angry because they're, oh, it could be a hanging, whatever, blah, blah, blah, future bug. I can't explain right now why this came up at work, but there's a context now in which we cannot do that ever again. I'll be able to explain why in a few months. But as soon as I became aware of this context where this was going to be problematic, I was like, well, this might affect people like me who write code this way. And everybody else in the team was like, nope, nope. I only write that code like that for slides. Bryce, you're out of your mind. You should like, well, this would be perfectly fine. Nobody really writes code this way. And I was like, all right, all right. If you guys tell me
不，我也这样做。然后大家就会非常生气，因为他们会觉得：“哦，这可能会导致悬空 else，不管怎样，巴拉巴拉，未来的 Bug。”我现在没法解释为什么在工作中会遇到这个，但现在有了一个背景，我们在这种情况下再也不能那样做了。几个月后我才能解释原因。但一旦我意识到这个背景会有问题时，我就想，好吧，这可能会影响像我这样写代码的人。而团队里的其他人则说：“不，不，我只在做幻灯片时才那样写代码。布莱斯，你疯了吧。你应该——”好吧，这其实完全没问题。根本没人真这么写代码。我当时就想：“好吧，好吧，既然你们都这么说
that, then fine. I surrender. And Connor, I know that you're now thinking about this and now you're wondering, is the only code that I write code for slides and that's why I don't use them? No, no. Well, so, yeah, I mean, I have no problem putting braces if it's code reviewed and people whine about it. I personally, in my own projects, will admit that stuff if I think it's abundantly clear. What do you think about the single line if? Like if the statement behind the if is really short i'll put it on the same line as yeah yeah i i we configured our rapids kudiaf like i was i wasn't
那好吧，我投降。”康纳，我知道你现在肯定在想这事，脑子里也在琢磨：难道我写的唯一代码就是幻灯片代码，这就是我不用大括号的原因吗？不，不。好吧，所以，是的，我的意思是，如果是经过代码审查而且别人抱怨的话，我加上大括号也没问题。我个人在自己的项目中，如果觉得已经极其清楚了，我就会省略那些东西。你觉得单行 if 怎么样？比如 if 后面的语句真的很短，我会把它放在同一行，就像——是的，是的，我——我们配置了我们的 Rapids CUDDF 的，就像——我当时并不是
in charge of setting the the config for clang format but i was the one that implemented it and people were allowed to review it but we have our setup such that short functions will have like all all the brace and the contents if it can fit in the column limit and if statements that are short uh go on the same line which then it sort of really irritates me then because if we have braces then you end up with like if predicate brace you know consequent and brace and like to me i just i really don't want to see those braces there but yeah it's not it's not the end of the world. You said you'd do the same thing, right? One of the reasons why I dislike adding the braces to the if statements is the coding convention that I was raised with, which was the coding convention of Hartmut Kaiser, the one that we used in HPX.
负责设置 Clang Format 配置的人，但我是那个实施它的人，大家都可以对其进行审查。不过我们的设置是这样的：短函数会把所有的括号和内容放在一行里（如果它能塞进列宽限制的话），而简短的 if 语句也会放在同一行。这样一来，它其实就会让我觉得很烦躁，因为如果我们有大括号，你最后就会写成：if 谓词和大括号，你知道的，结果在大括号里。对我来说，我真的不想看到那些大括号在那里，不过是的，这也不是世界末日。你刚才说你也会这样做，对吧？我之所以不喜欢在 if 语句中加括号的原因之一，是我所受的编码约定，也就是 Hartmut Kaiser 的编码约定，我们在 HPX 中用的就是那个。
We would always put the brace on a new line so we wouldn't dangle the brace at the end of the last line. And the main reason why, and this is also sort of a boostism, the main reason why I saw for doing this was when you're writing a function signature, if the function has a lot of arguments and the function signature takes up a few lines, if you put the opening brace for the function on the, the end of the last line of the function signature, um, it can be like a little bit jarring for the, some of the function signature to be indented more than the first line of the function body. Um, uh, and like, it's not apparent where the brace is.
我们总是把大括号放在新的一行，这样我们就不会把大括号悬挂在上一行的末尾。主要原因（这也是一种 Boost 风格）在于，当我看到这样做的原因时——当你编写函数签名时，如果函数有很多参数，并且函数签名占了好几行，如果你把函数的左大括号放在函数签名最后一行的末尾，嗯，对于函数体第一行来说，函数签名的一部分缩进比它还要多，这可能会让人觉得有点突兀。嗯，而且大括号在哪个位置也不是很明显。
And I always just felt like it was a little bit cleaner to have the brace be on its own line. And so for the if statements, I would just put it on its own line, just solely out of consistency. Now, I think if you're in a coding convention where you put the brace at the end of the last line, then there's less of an argument for omitting the braces on the
我一直觉得让大括号自成一行会更干净一些。所以对于 if 语句，我也会让它自成一行，完全是为了保持一致性。现在，我想如果你身处一种将大括号放在最后一行末尾的编码规范中，那么在 if 语句中省略大括号的理由就会少一些。因为如果你把大括号放在最后一行末尾，那么与省略大括号的情况相比，if 语句只多了一个大括号或多了一行。特别是如果你有一个 if-else，并且如果你的 else 语句包含了前一个 if 的右大括号，那么你实际上并没有增加太多东西。我也曾使用过那种编码规范，但它并不是我最喜欢的首选风格，我仍然倾向于让大括号自成一行。大括号是独立存在的，如果你愿意这么说的话。
if statement. Because if you put the brace on the end of the last line, then the if statement, you're only adding one extra brace or one extra line to the if statement than if you'd omitted the braces. And especially if you've got like an if else, and if your else statements have the closing brace for the previous if on them, then you're really not adding that much more. And I have used that coding convention a little bit, but it's not like my favorite preferred style, which is still to have the brace be on its own line. The brace stands alone, if you will. Yeah, in QDF, we have a mix. So like you said, oh, just for the sake of consistency kudief
是的，在 CUDDF 中，我们有各种风格的混合。所以就像你说的，哦，为了保持一致性，CUDDF 在函数上会断开，所以总是让大括号自成一行。其实我个人并不是很喜欢那样，但因为 CUDDF 大量使用了模板和 SFINAE（替换失败并非错误）之类的东西，你最终会遇到——就像你说的——一些奇怪的情况，比如函数签名被缩进，然后你有了大括号，然后函数体从哪里开始并不是真的很清楚，就像缩进然后有了大括号，然后函数体从哪里开始并不是真的很清楚。但对于 if 语句，我们把它们放在同一行末尾。不管怎样，我们本该讨论命名问题的，然而，我确实想回到这一切是如何开始的话题。我问——我问你对诸如冗余括号之类的东西有什么看法，你说你更倾向于过度使用括号。我应该强调一下，我不知道我们是否会把这些内容全部剪进这一集还是另一集，或者我索性把它剪掉。
it breaks on a function so always has the brace on its own line and i actually i don't personally prefer that but because kudief makes so much use of templates and sfine stuff you end up yeah like you said in some odd cases where the function signature is like indented and then you have the brace and then it's not really clear like where the start of the function body is like indented and then you have the brace and then it's not really clear like where the start of the function body is but for ifs we have them on the same at the end of the line but anyways we're supposed to be talking about naming however i do want to get back to how this all started i asked i asked how do you feel about un like redundant parentheses you said i prefer to over parenthesize i should highlight i don't know if we'll throw this all in to this episode or another episode, or I'll just cut it.
但如果它最终真的出现在某一集里，值得一提的是，有一个核心准则，即 41 或 ES41，上面写着：“如果对运算符优先级有疑问，请加上括号”，我是赞同这一点的。嘿，所以我对了。我百分之百正确。这正是我所说的。不过，有人提出了这样一个评论，我并不是在挑刺。我只是不太确定自己对此作何感想。比如，当我写 auto const 这一行时（你知道的，我会省略变量名），auto const A 等于 B 减去 C 再减去 D。然后评论建议给第一次减法（即 B 减去 C）加上括号，
But if it does end up in an episode, it's worth mentioning that there's a core guideline, 41 or ES41, but it says, if in doubt about operator precedence, parenthesize, which I agree with. Hey, so I'm right. I'm 100% right. Exactly what I said. However, this comment got made and it's not me being critical. I'm just not sure how I feel about it. Like, where I have the line autoconst, you know, I'll omit the names of the variables, but autoconst A equals B minus C minus D. And then the comment is to parenthesize the first subtraction, B minus C,
因为在语义上它实际上更接近实际发生的事情——就像你先减去前两个，然后再用它去减去第三个。然而，我认为这里对运算符优先级没有任何混淆，它更多是从正在发生的事情的语义角度出发的。而且我不——因为通常我喜欢——我喜欢和你相反，我喜欢简洁，只要它依然具有表现力——我更喜欢短小的东西。在一个三行的函数中，如果能明确看出 n 的作用，我完全不介意把局部变量命名为 n。但对于这个，我不知道，我不知道，我最后可能还是会把括号加上，但我对此并没有形成坚定的看法——如果括号
because it is actually semantically a little bit closer to what's happening like you are subtracting the first two and then from that subtracting the third thing however i don't think there's there's no confusion about operator precedence here it's more from like a semantic point of view of what's happening and i don't because like typically i like i like i'm the opposite of you i brevity as long as it's still expressive like I prefer short things I have no problem calling a local variable n in like a three-line function if it's explicitly clear what like n is doing but yeah for this I don't know I don't know I'll probably end up putting putting them in but I don't have a formed opinion on on this like if the parentheses
没有表达——如果它们没有在运算符优先级方面引入更多的清晰度，它们大概是在为正在发生的事情引入更多的含义，我不知道自己对这有什么感觉。所以——所以，你知道，我使用括号做奇怪事情的另一个时候是——如果我要为 if 语句编写一个条件，而这个条件有点冗长，并且会占用多行，我可能会在那里使用括号，让它变得更容易读懂一些。
are not expressing if they're not introducing clarity in terms of operator precedence they're supposedly introducing like more meaning to what's happening i don't know how i feel about that so so uh you know the the the other the other time when i do weird stuff with parentheses is um if i'm writing um a condition for an if statement and that condition's kind of meaty and it's going to take up multiple lines, I might use parentheses there to make it a little more readable.
我通常做的事情之一是，如果是一堆用 and 连接的子条件，我会尝试每行放一个，然后把逻辑与（and）放在条件接下来的每一行（你知道的，每一行）的开头。所以你会看到，你知道，在一行里，我会写 if，你知道，括号，然后是另一个括号，a 小于 c。然后在第二行，我会对齐所有我的。我会放逻辑与，然后把第二个条件放在括号里。
One of the things I typically do is if it's a bunch of like sub conditions that are all anded together I'll try to put one on each line and then I'll put the the logical and at the start of each of the set you know each of the following lines of the condition. So I'll have, you know, on one line, I'll have if, you know, parens, then another parens, a less than c. And then on the second line, I'll have aligned all mice. I'll have the logical and, and then I'll have the second condition in parentheses.
有时，当我编写这样更复杂的条件时，嗯，添加额外的括号会很有用，只是为了把一行代码更好地封装起来，或者让它看起来更好一点。是的，嗯——但我确实有一些自己遵循的奇怪的代码格式化习惯。比如我是艾布拉姆斯逗号（Abrams comma）的粉丝，也就是当你有一个逗号分隔的列表，并且它被分成了多行（其中每个不同的元素都在不同的一行）时，你不会把逗号放在最后一项的末尾，而是把它放在下一项的开头。据说——嗯，我相信这使得重新排列列表中的各项变得更容易。有些人觉得这非常难看。
And sometimes when i'm like writing more complex conditions like that um it it's useful to add additional parentheses just to sort of like encapsulate a line a little bit better or make it look a little bit better yeah um but i i i kind of have some weird code formatting things that I do. Like I'm a fan of the Abrams comma, which is where when you've got a comma separated list of something that's separated onto multiple lines where each different element is on a different line you don't put the comma at the end of the last item you put it at the start of the next item and this is supposedly well this i believe makes it easier to reorder things um around in the list um Some people think it's very ugly.
然后还有另一件事我做的是……等等，暂停，暂停。我以为这么做的动机是——而且它有好几种不同的风格。我以前不知道它叫艾布拉姆斯逗号，但我以为这样做的动机是，当你在列表末尾引入一个新项时，
And then there's another thing I do where... Wait, pause, pause. I thought the motivation for that, and there's a couple different flavors of it. I didn't know it was called the Abraham's comma, but I thought the motivation was that when you end up introducing an item at the end of the list,
你的 git diff 就只有一行，而不是两行（即顶行的多余逗号，或者你知道的，最后一个最新的项，然后是你的新项）。而如果它们组合在同一行，你只会得到一个绿色的新增项，而不会同时得到一个红色和一个绿色。是的，我想这也是动机之一。老实说，多年来我听过关于它的各种动机。这不是我这么做的原因。我这么做是因为这是我多年来一直采用的一种方式。嗯，呃，而且——我一直觉得这样更干净一些。我的意思是，我喜欢它的另一个原因是，嗯，它是——如果我——如果我，逗号在哪里更清晰，以及逗号在哪里更清晰，
your git diff is only one line as opposed to two of like the extra comma at the top line, or the you know, the last most recent item, and then your new item, whereas if it's at the, you know, if they're combined on the same line, you only get like a, you get a single green addition instead of one red and one green. Yeah, I think that's one of the motivations to I'll be perfectly honest, I've heard some number of motivations for it over the year. That's not why I do it. I do it because that's sort of the way that I've done it for a number of years. Um, uh, and, uh, I've just always found it a little bit cleaner. I mean, the other thing that I like about it is that, um, it's, uh, if I, if I'm, if I, it's more clear where the comma is and it's more clear where the comma is
如果我漏掉了一个逗号会更清晰，因为它总是在最前面。所以如果我做了这样的事情：我决定，“哦，你知道，这个函数的第一个参数实际上应该是第三个参数，诸如此类”，然后我把第一个参数移到第三个的位置，那么很明显我需要在第一个参数上加上一个逗号，并在最后一个参数上删掉一个逗号。而且我需要删除的那个逗号，它在这两行的列位置是相同的。
and it's more clear if I'm missing a comma because it's always at the front. So if I do something like I decide, oh, you know, the first argument of this function should actually be the third one or something and I move the first one down to be third, it's very obvious that I need to add a comma to the first one and remove a comma to the last one. And also the comma that I need to remove, it's in the same column position in
而如果逗号在末尾，它可能会处于不同的位置。所以这在视觉上会更清楚一点，嘿，我需要给其中一个加上逗号，然后从另一个上面去掉一个逗号。这就是为什么我觉得当我需要重新排列这些逗号分隔列表中的某项顺序时，它让我的生活变得更轻松了一点。而且我也发现，我更有可能会改变后续参数的顺序，而不是第一个参数的顺序；如果你把逗号放在行尾，那么特例就是最后一项，
both of those lines. Whereas if it's at the end, it might be in a different position. So it's just like a little bit visually clearer that, hey, I need to add a comma to one of these and remove a comma from another one of these. And so that's why I sort of think it makes my life a little bit easier when I'm going to change the order of something in one of these comma-separated lists. And also, I tend to find that I'm more likely to change the order of the subsequent arguments than the first argument and if you put the comma at the end of the line then the special case is the last one
而如果你把逗号放在行首，特例则是第一项。该死，我完全赞同这种做法，因为对称性更好，你可以实现逗号的垂直对齐。是的。但你刚才提到的第二点……不管怎样，原因有很多。不过我打断你了。
whereas if you put it at the start of the line the special case is the first one damn, I was totally on board with the there is more symmetry, you get vertical alignment of the commas. Yeah. But that second one that you just mentioned. Anyways, lots of reasons. I cut you off though.
你刚才在说……哇，解释一下你对我刚才说的话有什么意见。没什么意见。我只是，第一点我是赞同的。第二点。第二点，就没那么赞同了。这是——我的意思是，这是一个非常细粒度的部分，就像，从严格意义上讲，如果你看看比例的次数，这是一个真实的陈述，但就像第一点一样，会觉得“哦，我绝对能理解”。而第二点，我会觉得，你是在衡量次数的分布。
You were saying there was. Whoa, explain what problem you just had with what I just said. There's not a problem. I was just, the first one I was on board with. The second one. The second one, not so much. Is, I mean, that's a real, that's a real granular piece of like, well, technically speaking, if you look at the proportion of times, and it's a true statement, but just like the first one was like, oh, I could definitely see that. The second one, I'm like, you're measuring the distribution of like times.
就像我修改了这个带作用域的枚举，这里有一个直方图，记录了我更改每一行的次数。如果你把最后一行和第一行进行对比，次数会更少，这可能是真的。这很可能是真的。康纳，你必须明白，我是在为相当于仪式的行为编造正当理由。这就是仪式。它没有任何根源——比如，我完全乐意使用我合作的代码库所采用的任何编码规范，只是——这就是——这是我的传承，康纳，这就是我当年写代码的风格，而我喜欢为此编造一个正当理由，并且
Like I modified this scoped enumerator, and there's a histogram on the number of times I've changed each of these lines. And if you compare the last versus the first, it's less, which is probably true. It's probably true. Connor, you have to understand I am inventing justification for what amounts to ritual. This is ritual. It's not rooted in any, like, I will happily use whatever coding convention is the coding convention of a code base i work with it's just this is this is the this is my heritage connor this is this is the style in which i i wrote code back in the day and uh i like to invent a justification for it and
以防万一——我想我可能会把这段剪成单独的一集。所以对于正在收听的听众，我完全同意布莱斯的观点：不管是什么规范，我都会使用它。可能你也同意这一点，布莱斯：比起规范究竟是什么，我更在乎的是“必须得有个规范”，因为我实在不想在代码审查中看到大家争论诸如“哦，你知道，巴拉巴拉，你没有对齐这个”之类的问题。我只希望有一个格式化工具能帮我搞定这一切。话虽如此，我非常关心我个人代码的外观。所以在代码库中，比如我目前参与的项目之一 Thrust，这是一个大约有 10 年历史的开源项目。它是一个包含了一堆衍生自 Boost 的代码、一堆来自不同项目的代码的项目。这个项目里可能包含来自四五种不同许可证的代码，比如两个版本的 BSD、MIT、Boost，全都是从不同地方、在不同时间点搜集来的代码。而且这些代码从来没有运行过 Clang Format。所以 Thrust 项目的经验法则是：你顺从你所在的那个代码区域的风格，而那甚至不一定是整个文件。它可能类似于：我正在处理的这组函数是一种风格，而在这个头文件往下 300 行的地方，就会是另一种风格。这实际上也是我在来到 NVIDIA 之前参与的另一个项目中代码格式化运作的方式。我职业生涯头五年的大部分时间都在那个项目（HPX）中度过。在 HPX 中，Hartmut、我和其他主要开发人员有着相似的代码风格，
in case in case uh i think this probably i'll cut this into a separate episode. So for those that are listening, I completely agree with Bryce, whatever the convention is, I will, I will use that. Probably Bryce, you agree that I care so much more that there just is a convention than like what the convention is, because I just don't want there to be like arguments in code reviews about like, oh, you know, blah, blah, blah, you didn't align this. I just want there to be a formatter that does it for me. That being said, like, I care so much what my personal code looks like. So in the code base, like one of the code bases, I currently work on Thrust, which is about a 10 year old open source project. And it, it's a project that has a bunch of code that's derivative from Boost, a bunch of code that's
但并不是 100% 相似。所以有些文件我一看就会觉得：“哦，是的，这个是我写的，从风格一眼就能看出来。这是 Hartmut 写的，从风格也能看出来。这是 Hartmut 在 2012 年写的，因为那是他当时使用的风格。”我想他们后来对那个代码库运行了 Clang Format。我的团队一直讨论要对 Thrust 运行 Clang Format，这可能是一个好主意，但当所有这些历史都被格式化掉时，我会觉得有点难过，不过这大概会大大提高可读性。
from like different projects. There's probably code from like four or five different licenses in the project, like both versions of BSD, MIT, Boost, just code taken from a whole bunch of different places at a bunch of different times. And it's all never been clang formatted so the rule of thumb in thrust is you follow the style of whatever precinct of the code you happen to be in and that that's not even necessarily the file it's like it might be like this set of functions that i'm working on have one style and like 300 lines down in this header, there's going to be a different style. And this was actually sort of how code formatting worked in the other project I worked on prior to being at NVIDIA, which I spent most of the first five years of my career on, HPX, where in HPX, Hartmut and I and the other main developers had similar code styles,
我觉得在一个……那么，当时主要就是你和 Hartmut 在那个代码库上工作吗，当你……当我——我是 Hartmut 招进来的第一个人。我是 HPX 的第二号开发者。第三号开发者是托马斯·海勒（Thomas Heller）。这些年来我们还招了许多其他伙伴，但在早期阶段，主要是我和 Hartmut，比如我刚开始工作的头六个月。
but not 100% similar. And so there were certain files that I could look at and I'd be like, okay, yeah, this is one that I wrote. I can just tell from the style. And this is one that Hartmut wrote that I could tell from the style. This is one that Hartmut wrote in 2012 because that was the style he was using then. I think they've since clang formatted that code base. My team keeps talking about clang formatting thrust, which is probably a good idea, but I'll be a little bit sad when all of that history gets formatted away, but it'll probably greatly improve readability.
是的，所以我觉得在这种情况下，不使用 Clang Format 或任何格式化工具实际上可以运作得相当好，因为——好吧，当时 Clang Format 根本不存在，那是 2011 年，所以我的意思是，你也得把这一点考虑进去。但就算在今天，如果你一个项目里只有两个人，我觉得它也完全可以运作得很好。因为我实际上有一大堆抱怨——我觉得 Clang Format 做得非常惊艳，但是像——有许多事情，比如表格化（tabular）格式化可能是最大的批评点。如果你有一个 switch-case 语句，里面有许多不同长度的枚举值，并且每个 case 语句都只是返回一个单一的表达式，
I think that like in a... So was it just you and HeartMid primarily working on that code base when you were, you know... When I... I was the first person that HeartMid brought on. I was like developer number two on HPX. And then developer number three was Thomas Heller. And then we had a whole bunch of other folks come in over the years but like in the in the very early stages it was mostly me and heartmit um like the first six months that i was working on it
你希望那些 return 语句对齐。你希望 case 语句对齐。case 会对齐，但基本上其他什么都不会对齐。同样地，如果你有一个 switch-case 语句，里面包含一个表达式、分号，然后是 break，你希望所有表达式的起始位置都对齐，然后 break 也能对齐，但 Clang Format 绝对会彻底搞砸。不使用格式化工具，而只是让两个彼此熟悉对方编码风格的人来写，实际上可以产出更好看的代码。问题在于，当开发者不是两个人，而是——你知道的，N 个人——
yeah so i think i think in that situation like going clang format free or like format or free actually can work like quite well because well clang format didn't exist at the time this was 2011 so i mean take that take that into consideration as well but just like even even today if you only have two people working on a project i think it can work totally fine because i actually have like a ton of grievances like i think i think clang format has done amazingly but like if like there are a bunch of things like tabular tabular formatting is probably like the biggest criticism like if you have a switch case statement with you know a bunch of things like tabular, tabular formatting is probably like the biggest criticism. Like if you have a switch case statement with, you know, a bunch of different length enumerators and every case statement is just like a single expression returned.
其中 N 不是一个小数目，并且这 N 个人并没有处于相同的频率上。然后你就会收到一些 Pull Request，明显能看出写代码的人没有那么关注他们的代码看起来怎么样。接着你就要花掉代码审查的前三次迭代，反复来回地说：“请把这里改得更具可读性一点。”是的。所以，实际上我可能挺喜欢不用 Clang Format 的。如果只有我一个人，我可能一直都会这么做。我用 Clang Format 的痛点在于——这可能只是我脾气不好、抗拒新事物——有很多时候，我会做一些仅在局部有意义的格式化。比如，你知道，也许我有
Like you want those returns aligned. You want like the cases a lot. The cases will be aligned, but basically nothing else will. Similarly, if you have like a case switch case statement with like an expression, semicolon, then break, you want all of the starts of the expressions to be aligned and then the breaks to be aligned and like claim format absolutely just like falls over not having a formatter and just having two people that you're both familiar with each other's coding styles can actually lead to like nicer looking code the problem is that when you have not two developers but like you know n developers what
一系列的 if 和 else if，我想把条件的起始括号对齐。或者也许我在某个地方连续声明了四个彼此相似的变量，我想把等号对齐。但也许在后面的某个地方，比如，你知道，也许有些变量紧随其后声明，而我不想让等号对齐，因为如果那样做的话，会把行拉得太长，导致折行。这就像我在格式化代码时，会有大量针对特殊情况的处理。我总是担心格式化工具会把这些搞砸。我从来没真正用过 Clang Format。
where n is not a small number, and end people aren't like operating on the same wavelength. And then you get pull requests, where clearly the person hasn't like paid as much attention to how their code looks. And then you spend like the first three iterations of the code review going back and forth saying, you know, please make this a little bit more readable. Yeah. So, so I actually probably like going clang format free. If it was just like me, I might do that all the time. My problem with clang format, and this is probably just me being grumpy and resistant to new things is that there's a lot of times when I will do some formatting that makes sense locally only. Like, you know, maybe I've got, you know,
所以我想我对这个说法的实际依据并不多。我只是从来没有真正觉得有这个需要。尽管我参与过一些非常大型、拥有大量开发人员的项目，但我从来没有遇到过那种想跟别人争论格式化问题的情况。如果我在审查对某个项目的贡献，而它使用了不同的编码规范，其实并不会困扰我。我挺能接受这一点的。
a series of if and else ifs where I want to align the starting parens of the condition. Or maybe I've got, you know, in one place I declare four variables in a row where they're all sort of similar and I want the equal sign to line up. But maybe there's another place later, like, you know, maybe there's some variables that are clear right after that where I don't want the equal signs lined up because if I did that, then it would make the line too long and it would break across the line. It's just like when I'm formatting my code, there's a whole bunch of special cases that I'll make. And I always worry that a formatter is just going to muck those up. I've never really used Clang format.
如果它与文件的其余部分不一致，我可能会提一些意见。我唯一能记起因此要求做修改的格式化问题只有缩进。比如：“嘿，你缩进了四个空格，而这个文件的其余部分缩进了两个。你能改成缩进两个空格吗？”但我不懂。这真的不会困扰我。
So I don't suppose I have much actual justification for that claim. I've just never really found a need for it. Even though I've worked on some projects that are very large, that have a lot of developers, I've never been in the case where I've wanted to argue with somebody over formatting. If I'm code reviewing a contribution to a project I'm working on and it uses a different coding style, that doesn't really bother me. I'm kind of okay with that.
这让我想起了我最喜欢的托尼·瓦纳（Tony Van Eerd）演讲中的一个时刻，那是他在 CppCon 上发表的演讲……还有 C++ Now。2017 年名为《后现代 C++》（Postmodern C++）的演讲。在那场演讲中，他首先全程都用押韵的方式发言。所以这是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。你们一定要去看。他全程都在押韵。我得去看看。
If it's inconsistent with the rest of the file, I might make some remark about it. The only thing I can remember asking for changes for that was like a formatting thing was indentation. Like, hey, you're indenting by four spaces and the rest of this file is indented by two. Can you indent by two instead? But I don't know. It just doesn't really bother me.
我已经看过它的所有三个版本了。听众们必须得去看。是的。这看起来好像只是一场滑稽搞笑的演讲，但实际上它并不仅仅是一场滑稽搞笑的演讲。它包含了一些非常深刻的、关于编程的现实世界教训。他所说的话之一就是：“在我的代码中，我会在不同的风格之间切换。我让具体情况来决定哪种风格更有价值。”这触及了他整场演讲的核心，也就是“后现代 C++”这个概念。
This brings to mind a moment from my favorite Tony Vanner talk, which is one that he gave at CppCon... And C++ Now. 2017 called Postmodern C++. And in that talk, he spoke in rhyme for the entire talk, first of all. So it's an amazing talk. You have to go watch it. The entire talk, he spoke in rhyme. I have to go watch it.
而这些后现代的理念之一，就是后现代的编码规范就是“不设任何固定的编码规范”。托尼的意思其实正是我刚才所说的那样：你不应该有一套被无条件应用到各处的、严格的格式化准则。相反，你应该使用在当前那部分代码中看起来最有意义的编码风格。我非常认同这一点。每当我提到这句名言，它总是让我想起《加勒比海盗》的那个梗：
I've seen all three versions of it. The listeners need to go watch it. Yeah. And it seems like it's just like a funny humorous talk, but it's not actually just a funny humorous talk. It has some very deep, like real world lessons about programming. And one of the things he says is in my code, I switch between styles. I let the circumstances determine which is worthwhile. And that sort of gets to the whole core of his talk, which is this idea of postmodern C++.
代码与其说是实际的规则，不如说是你所谓的指导方针。代码与其说是实际的规则，不如说是你所谓的指导方针。代码与其说是实际的规则，不如说是你所谓的指导方针。我认为不仅格式化准则是这样的，库的设计准则、命名政策和命名模式也是如此。我们上周开了一场库演进小组（C++ Library Evolution group）的会议，讨论了一些拟议中的库设计准则和命名准则。
And one of these postmodern ideas is that the postmodern coding convention is to not have any fixed coding convention. And what Tony means by that is sort of exactly what I just said, that you shouldn't have a rigorous set of formatting guidelines that is applied unconditionally everywhere. You should instead use the coding style that makes sense in the particular part of the code that you're in. And I really connect like that. And whenever I mention this quote, it always brings to mind, to me, the Pirates of the Caribbean meme of, you know,
那次会议得出的结论之一是，我们某种程度上表示：“你知道的，我们不想规定硬性规则。我们能说的最强硬的话是：如果你在给一个满足这个标准的事物命名，那么你应该考虑诸如这样的名字。它应当是候选之一。或者如果你在做 X，你应该考虑这个。”会议期间，我的朋友莱恩·古格（Ryan Google）提出了这样一个观点——这是在谈到给某些事物的名称添加特定的前缀或后缀时提到的——他建议应该把“修饰”作为最后手段。你应该严格遵守规则，但如果为了消除歧义等原因需要它，规则或建议的模式可能会有所帮助。我认为这确实
the code is more what you'd call guidelines than actual rules. The code is more what you'd call guidelines than actual rules. The code is more what you'd call guidelines than actual rules. And I think this is something that's true for not just formatting guidelines, but also for library design guidelines, and also for naming policies and naming patterns. We had a meeting of Library Evolution, the C++ Library Evolution group, last week where we talked about some proposed library design guidelines and naming guidelines.
抓住了 C++ 标准库设计的核心：我们尽量不强制执行硬性规则。我们努力去做对我们正在处理的具体事物最有意义的事情。好了。所以我大概有三四件不同的事情要说，但我一件也不打算说，因为我们需要把话题切换到命名上。不，不，不，不，不，不。去吧，去聊吧。我们得保持流畅。
And one of the things that came out of that meeting was we sort of said, you know, we don't want to prescribe hard rules. The strongest thing we want to say is if you're naming something that meets this criterion, then you should consider a name like this. It should be one of the candidates. Or if you're doing X, you should consider this. And somebody during that meeting, my friend Ryan Google, said this was in reference to adding a particular prefixes or suffixes to names of certain things. And he suggested that the policy should be decorated as a last resort. you should rigorously follow the rule, but the rule or the suggested pattern may be helpful if you need it to clear up something that's ambiguous, et cetera. And I think this really
我们得顺其自然——我得提一下，这些都会剪进去，我会提一下这些话题，然后我们会有另一集，因为我要说的话还有很多。所以，我完全同意，回到——好吧，首先，是的，托尼，托尼的所有演讲都很棒，嗯，绝对是《后现代 C++》，他给出了好几种不同的变体，强烈推荐，我们肯定会把它放在Shownotes里。你提到过，在局部做出某些格式化决策（比如对齐等号）时，在其他上下文中，当然了，当你决定 Clang Format 配置时，你会看三份文件。你会看三到五份文件，也许更多。
captures sort of the core of C++ standard library design, that we try to not rigorously enforce rules. We try to do what makes sense for the particular thing we're working on. All right. So I have like three or four different things to say, but I'm not going to say any of them because we need to switch to our naming. No, no, no, no, no, no. Go, go, talk. We got to flow.
但你不会这么做。如果你的代码库有成百上千个文件，你不会去检查里面的每一个文件。所以理所当然地，不可避免地，局部看起来很好。然后你没有考虑到这一个特例，结果它看起来就糟糕透顶了。我未来想在某一集中探讨的事情，是一个我实际上从未谈论过的话题，因为我确信自己会因此招来大量骂声。但它是我脑海中一直在思考的东西，叫做“格式驱动开发”（format-driven development）。它紧挨着“常量驱动开发”（const-driven development），就像那种非常、非常易读的代码，以及你在不考虑代码将如何被格式化的情况下最终写出来的代码之间，其语义差异其实并没有那么大。不管怎样，我们会在以后的节目中讨论这个。我们今天就聊到这里。感谢收听，祝大家过愉快的一天！本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
We got to let it just i will i will mention this is all going in i will mention the topics and then we will have another episode because i have a lot more to say but so i totally agree going back to well so first of all yes tony all of tony's talks are awesome uh but definitely postmodern c++ he's given a couple different variations highly recommend it we'll put it in the show notes for sure. You mentioned about how locally when you're making certain formatting decisions and like aligning of equal signs that like in other contexts, you know, sure enough, you look at three files when you're deciding on your Clang format config. You look at, you know, three or five files or maybe more than that.
我们得让它——我顺便提一下，这些都会播进去——我先提一下主题，然后我们再录一期，因为我还有很多话要说。不过我完全同意，回到刚才说的，首先，是的，托尼，托尼所有的演讲都很棒，呃，但绝对推荐他的《现代C++》，他讲过好几个不同的版本，非常推荐，我们肯定会把它放在Shownotes里。你提到在本地做某些格式化决策时，比如对齐等号，在其他情况下，当然，你在决定Clang format配置时会看三个文件。你会看，嗯，三五个文件，或者可能更多。
But you're not going to do it. You're not going to go through every single file in your code base if it's hundreds and hundreds of files. So sure enough, inevitably, like locally, it looks good. And then you didn't consider this one case, and it ends up looking awful. And the thing that I want to talk about in a future episode is something that like, I've actually never talked about, because I'm pretty sure I'm just going to get a ton of hate for it. But it's, it's something that I sort of inside my head I think about is format-driven development. And it goes right next to const-driven development, which it's like like really, really readable code and the semantic, you know, difference between what you would have ended up writing without thinking about like how
但你不会真的这么做。如果你的代码库有成百上千个文件，你不可能去遍历其中的每一个文件。所以不出所料，不可避免地，在本地看起来不错。然后你没有考虑到某一种情况，结果看起来就一团糟。我想在以后的节目中谈论的是一件我从未谈论过的事情，因为我很确定我会因此招来大批骂声。但它——在我脑海里，我把它称为格式驱动开发。它紧挨着const驱动开发，就像真正、真正可读的代码以及你如果不考虑
it's going to be formatted isn't isn't too far off. Anyways, we'll talk about that in a future episode. And that's where we'll call it. Thanks for listening and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它将如何格式化而最终编写的代码之间的语义差异并不是太大。总之，我们会在以后的节目中讨论这个。今天的节目就到这里。谢谢收听，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。